>> Okay, I want to continue this very long message from the 14th of September 1917.
We will finish it talking about these windbags.
That's new language for you.
So she has just told us how wonderful it is.
To be in the divine will.
So I'll take up at her last statement, and then you'll see that we begin now with a contrast to that.
So the soul in the divine will has nothing of her own, but everything is in common with Jesus.
Her passion is the divine will.
Her characteristic is the will of her Jesus, and the fiat is her continuous motto.
On the other hand, you do know it's Jewish characteristics to say on the one hand,
and on the other hand, don't you remember the piddler on the roof?
On the other hand, at the poor and false sanctity, that's the windbags,
of the balloons is subject to continuous inconsistencies.
And while it seems that the balloons of their sanctity swell,
so much as to seem to be flying in the air at a certain height, to the point that many
and even their directors are amazed, soon they are disillusioned.
In other words, that they can appear to have spiritual experiences
that would indicate that this is real sanctity, but it doesn't continue.
It's only a flash in the pan.
One humiliation, or watch this now, one preference of the directors towards somebody else
is enough to make these balloons deflate for they believe that this is a theft
against them considering themselves the neediest.
Now, the strange thing is human beings can twist anything.
Now, while it's the most wonderful thing to live in,
you're nothing is in all the rest of it.
It's another matter to fight over who is the neediest.
It's exactly the same thing as fighting over who is the greatest.
It actually doesn't matter.
You're fighting with your neighbor over some preference or preferential position.
Isn't this extraordinary?
Now she's actually referring to the people in her own day who were lined up
to talk to these spiritual directors.
I don't know how the priests put up with it, but they did.
And then if somebody was given preference before them, they were all obsessed
and all the rest of it.
And I've been passed over and what kind of sanctity is that?
OK, that's what she says.
One humiliation or someone being preferred before them.
Therefore, while having scruples about trifles, then they reach the point
of disobeying and you notice that obedience is one
of the great signs of the divine will.
Jealousy is the woodworm of these balloons which consuming the good
that they do keeps sucking air from them and the poor balloon deflates
and falls to the ground reaching the point of dirtying itself with the earth.
Now, the example I'm going to give you, I apologize ahead of time in case I walk
on all your cards, not just one of them.
I don't know how much experience you have of being in prayer groups,
but in charismatic prayer groups, one of the things that has literally brought
the whole thing down is jealousy.
How did you get this, the gift of prophecy and I didn't get it?
Why did you get the gift of healing and I didn't get it?
I'm just as good as you are.
How did you get to the position of being a leader?
Why should be a leader?
Can't you see?
It's all the wrong spirit and the person saying that has not in fact been
converted, has not in fact put themselves aside, has not in fact discovered divine
love. That's why I'm giving you that example.
And it can destroy them and prayer groups have fallen apart simply because
of jealousy about gifts and stuff.
Then the sanctity that was in this balloon disappears and what do you find?
Love of self, resentment, passions hidden under the aspect of good,
almost to have the occasion to say they've made themselves the amusement of the
devil. Isn't that really sad?
So of all their sanctity, nothing was found but a mass of defects,
apparently disguised as virtues.
But then who can say everything?
Only Jesus knows the worst evils of this false sanctity of this devout life
without foundation, which has a false piety.
So I want to give you the true piety then, which is Ephesians chapter three
verses 14 to 21. This is the true piety.
And Ephesians chapter three tells you that your foundation is Christ,
that you are built on love and that your perfection is love and that you reach
the fullness of love. That's the true thing.
But what Louisa is describing here is the false thing.
These false sanctities are the spiritual lives without fruit.
They're sterile and they are the cause of who knows how much crying on the part
of our beloved Jesus.
They are the ill feeling of society, the worries of their directors and of their
families. It can be said that they bring with themselves a noxious air that harms
everyone. In other words, to use one word for the whole thing, she says,
they're toxic.
And it can be a mercy of God that if this kind of thing gets into a prayer
group, that the Lord allows the prayer group to disintegrate, to save the individuals.
Okay. Oh, how so very different is the sanctity of the soul who lives in the divine
will. These souls are the smile of Jesus.
They're far away from everyone, even from the very directors.
In other words, they're not looking for attention at all from anyone.
Only Jesus is everything for them.
Therefore, nobody worries about them.
The beneficial air that they possess in bams all.
They are the order and the harmony of everyone.
Now, she's describing two completely different spirits.
One is healing and the other is toxic.
Jesus, who is jealous of these souls, makes himself the actor and the spectator
of whatever they do.
There's not one heartbeat, breath or thought, which he does not regulate and dominate.
Jesus keeps this soul so absorbed in the divine will that she can hardly remember
that she's living in the exile.
It's a very good description of Louisa herself.
So September the 18th, 1917, the effects of constancy in good.
Continuing my usual state, I was in it in the midst of pains.
More so since my celestial mother had made herself seen crying.
And as I asked her, "My mother, why are you crying?"
She told me, "My daughter, how could I not cry?"
Since the fire of divine justice would want to devour everything.
The fire of sin devours all souls, the good of souls.
And the fire of justice wants to destroy all that belongs to them.
Notice fire on fire.
And in seeing the fire running, she said, "I cry."
She's crying because she wants all souls to be saved.
Then as I was lamenting to Jesus about his privations, it seemed to me
that without him I could take no more.
And my beloved Jesus moved to compassion for my poor soul, came
and transforming me into himself told me, "My daughter, have patience."
Because patience and constancy in good places everything in safety.
Even more, I tell you that when you deprived of me,
fight between life and death for the pain of your being without your Jesus.
And in spite of this, you remain constant in good and you neglect nothing.
And you do nothing other than squeeze yourself.
And in squeezing, love of self-natural satisfactions come out.
Your nature remains as though undone.
And what is left is a juice so pure and sweet, which I take so much delight in.
That I am sweetened and I look at you with so much love and tenderness as to feel your pains
as if they were my own.
Now, this is actually very important.
Jesus is saying that if you are constant in your living in the divine will,
the good that's going to come out of that is immeasurable.
And the test of constancy is when something goes wrong
or something, a time becomes difficult for you.
And you're not able to pray.
I think I told you that when my eye crisis started that I said to the Lord,
"I can't pray. I can't think.
I couldn't say a holy prayer."
If you put the words in front of me, well, I couldn't see them anyway.
So I said, "No matter what I do, I can't pray."
I'd start the rosary and I'd forget two minutes later that I'd started it.
And he said, "Walk."
I said, "Yeah, that's wonderful."
And then I, what you do is you don't question it, you just do it.
And I started to walk and the facility to pray came back in the walking
because in sitting down you were too concentrated on what was wrong.
And so he gives you very, very simple solutions to problems, very simple.
But we do need to ask him, and that was why I said to him,
"I didn't say to anybody else, I can't pray."
So he says that when the time is difficult and you remain constant and good
and you don't neglect what you're supposed to do, you know, in your prayers
and your duties in your state and life and everything, he said,
this squeezing, that means that you are demanding more of yourself.
That helps you to squeeze out love of self.
So all I can think of there is squeezing a lemon and out comes the juice.
Okay, or any other fruit that has juice in it.
Natural satisfaction, he comes out because he wants you to end up not,
we start out with natural satisfactions, but he wants you to end up with divine
satisfactions, okay?
And because of this, he said, what's coming out of you spiritually is so pure
that it is something that the Lord really enjoys.
And in the same way, if you are cold or dry, he means in prayer and the like,
and you remain constant, you give as many more squeezes to yourself
and you form more juice from my embittered heart.
So this is this wonderful juice of pure love.
It happens as with the prickly fruit with the hard skin,
but which contains a sweet and useful substance inside.
If the person is constant in removing the prickles and squeezing the fruit,
he will extract all the substance of the fruit and will enjoy the best of that fruit.
So the poor fruit has remained empty of the good that is contained.
Even more, the prickles and the skin have been thrown away.
It's the same for the soul.
In coldness, in aridities, she throws natural satisfactions to the ground.
She empties herself of herself, and through constancy, she squeezes herself.
That means you push yourself.
And the soul remains with the pure fruit of good, and I enjoy the sweetness of it.
So if you are constant, everything will serve you as good.
Now, that's Romans 828.
For those who love God, all things turn to the good.
Everything will serve you as good, and I will place my graces with confidence in you understood.
That's a nice little piece.
So the next one is September the 28th, 1917, and this is about acts.
Now, I don't know if you give yourself signs, but I give myself signs
so that I know where to find things.
I'll write acts there.
And so if I need to go back and find a reference to acts, I see my own word acts in the thing.
So in this section, the Lord is going to talk about the importance of acts
in the divine will.
So he said to Louisa, "My daughter, darkness is thick, and souls precipitate even more."
Now, he's talking about the world problems in September 1917.
Now, when he says that souls precipitate, that means fall into the abyss.
They're falling more towards the abyss, and the darkness, of course, is spiritual darkness.
So I want to give you Genesis 6.5, and of course, I should have given you a reference to Exodus as well.
I can't remember the exact reference now, but it's three days of darkness,
which were the result of sin, and the book of Exodus says that the darkness was so thick you could feel it.
Now, darkness and light are not material, so you can't reach out and touch darkness,
just as you can't reach out and touch light.
So if they tell you in the book of Exodus that the darkness was so thick you could feel it,
it's the presence of the demonic.
It's not the absence of light, it's the presence.
So, since Jesus is talking about this awful spiritual darkness,
then you have the presence of the demonic as well.
In this darkness, they are digging the precipice in which they will perish.
In other words, the less spiritual light that they have,
the more they will beat their enemies of their own selves.
The mind of man has remained blind, so I want to give you John 9.41,
where the Pharisees said to Jesus, "We're not blind, surely?"
He said, "If you were, I could heal you, but you say you can see, therefore no healing is available."
I want to give you Matthew 16.23.
The mind of man has remained blind, so that is in spiritual darkness.
It has no more light to look at good, but only at evil.
And evil will inundate him and make him perish.
I want to give you Jeremiah 4.14.
Jeremiah 4.14.
And I want to give you Matthew 13.14.15.
So, they're walking in darkness, and the darkness will enable them to go much deeper.
Now, I think that Matthew 13 is the blind leading, the blind, and they both fall into the ditch, do you remember?
So, therefore they believed they would find escape, they would find death.
The day are all the politicians who are making all these decisions, and millions of people die as a result of it.
And instead of finding solutions that they thought would solve the problems of the world,
all they've done is brought on terrible death, not only spiritual death, but physical death as well.
So, in the next paragraph, we go on to the power of a divine act.
But before that, I want to give you Matthew 23, verses 17 to 26.
Then Jesus added, "The acts done in my will are like suns which illuminate all souls."
The little word "all" there is "all souls."
And as long as the act of the soul in my will lasts, one more sun shines in the blind mind.
So, you wonder why they spoke about the blindness in paragraph 1.
It's because in paragraph 2, Jesus wanted to give you the solution.
So, with all the spiritual blindness that we have today in Ireland and throughout the world,
we have the answer to that, and that acts in the divine will that will bring light to them.
So, as long as the act of the soul in my will lasts, one more sun shines in the blind mind.
And those who have a little bit of good will find the light to escape from the precipice.
That means they'll find their way to salvation.
As for the others, they'll all perish.
In other words, if they haven't even got the good to want to get out of their situation,
then, unfortunately, their souls will perish, which is very frightening.
Therefore, in these times of thick darkness, and I notice the thick darkness, again,
the thickness is the presence of evil rather than the absence of light.
In these times of thick darkness, how much good the acts of the soul done in my will do.
For those who will escape, it will be only by virtue of these acts.
Would you ever put an envy, VIP?
Please note beside that.
The people in our world who will escape the terrors of the spiritual death that's all around us,
it's because of the divine will acts which will affect them.
That puts us in a very responsible position, doesn't it?
So, Jesus withdrew at that point.
In the next paragraph, we have what, in my opinion, is the most extraordinary image
of Jesus in these writings.
Jesus is a divine chariot, and he's the charioteer as well.
Now, that's straight out of the Old Testament thinking, okay.
When he came back again and he added, "I can say of the soul who does my will and lives
in it that she is my carriage, that is the chariot, and I hold the reins of everything."
Now, if you know anything about the Book of Exodus or the early part of the Old Testament,
the kings and the nobles were the ones who rode in chariots.
So, if you're the one holding the reins of the horses, you're the one in charge of the
entire battle.
If you go to Revelation 19 verses 11 to 21, the description of Jesus coming back in glory
is of him riding on horses or coming in a chariot, okay?
So, we are his carriage.
Now, if we think of this that I bring Jesus to where he wants to go, that's very important.
So, a little question you could ask in the morning, early in the morning is, "Jesus,
where do you want to go today?"
And he might say, "Well, let's visit purgatory.
Let's visit the houses where people are dying.
Let's visit the hospitals where people should be born, but they're not going to be born,
they're going to be killed."
And he'd bring you to all kinds of places that he wants you to go.
And it's very interesting to ask him the question, "Jesus, where do you want to go today?"
Because we're the carriage.
Okay.
"I hold the reins in her mind," she says, "that's two Corinthians 10, five.
I hold the reins of her affections, I hold the reins of her desires, and I leave not one
of them in her power, because otherwise there'd be trouble, wouldn't there?"
Now let me give you that in different language.
"Jesus sits on his throne in our hearts as the king of love, and he wants to reign on
the earth from the throne of our hearts."
Isn't that a beautiful image?
That might be more slightly more modern than the chariot.
And sitting upon her heart in order to be more comfortable, my dominion is complete.
And I do whatever I want.
Now my dominion is complete, is that the soul is completely surrendered, and therefore
the Lord can in fact do what he wants.
Sometimes I make the carriage run, or I make it fly.
And then it brings me to heaven, or I go around the whole earth, and then I stop.
That's why I said, "Jesus, where do you want to go?"
Okay.
"Oh, how glorious and victorious I am, and I dominate and rule."
So then there's a little warning given to us in the next short paragraph, that either
Jesus is the charioteer, or Satan takes the reins, you choose.
But if the soul doesn't do my will, and lives out of her own human will, the carriage falls
apart.
He takes the reins away from me, and I remain without dominion, like a poor king cast out
of his kingdom.
And the enemy takes my place, while the reins remain at the mercy of all her passions.
So if you want to put one word for that paragraph, just right in the margin, disorder, because
that's the one word that fits there.
And by comparison with that, the paragraph before that, you can just write down divine
order.
So your choice is divine order, or disorder.
So now we come to October the 4th, 1917, and Jesus is going to come in great bitterness
to Louisa, because in October 1917, the terrible Bolshevik Revolution happened.
You had the death of the Romanovs, and you have the death of the Orthodox Church followed
it, and literally millions of martyrs that knows the exact number.
So dreadful stuff happening now.
So you'll understand why the reading before this talks about tick darkness.
Okay.
This is the value of having a full day of this that you can see that this connects with
this, and that connects with that.
So this morning, my beloved Jesus transported me outside of myself, and he was in my arms
with his face so very close to mine, kissing me very softly.
It's a beautiful image of Jesus, isn't it?
As if he didn't want me to perceive it, but after he repeated his kisses, I could not
contain myself from requiting him with my kisses, and while I was kissing him, the talk
came to me of kissing his most holy lips to try and suckle the bitterness.
Now, that's the song of songs, chapter 1 and verses 1 to 2.
Let him kiss me with the kisses of his mouth.
And in case you think that there's a romantic attachment to that, you need to know that St.
Bernard of Clairvaux, who was the uncrowned king of the 12th century, gave at least four
sermons on this one sentence.
Let him kiss me with the kisses of his mouth.
And if you can't access Bernard's sermons, I'll give you the most important line of the
four of them.
He said, "If you are going to want to kiss the Lord on the lips," he said, "you have
to remember, you will only meet bitterness and gall."
That's all he has.
That's all human beings gave him.
And so, here Louisa is saying, "I want to kiss those lips.
I want to draw the bitterness."
How do you see it?
So you don't put any romantic attachment onto this.
So the talk came to me of kissing his most holy lips and tried to suckle his bitterness
that he contained.
"Who knows?
Jesus might surrender," said and done.
I kissed him and I tried to suckle, but nothing would come out.
I prayed him to pour his bitterness into me.
Again, I suckled with more strength, nothing.
It seems that my Jesus suffered from the efforts I was making over him, and after I repeated
with ardor for the third time, I felt the breath of Jesus most bitter coming into me.
And I saw something hard across the throat of Jesus that could not come out and prevented
the bitterness that he contained from coming out so that he might pour it to me.
And then Jesus almost crying told me, "My daughter, resign yourself," he said.
"Don't you see the hardness man has put into me with sin, which prevents me from sharing
my bitterness with one who loves me?
Don't you remember when in the past I would tell you, let me act otherwise man will reach
the point of doing so much evil as to almost exhaust evil itself?
Don't forget the Bolshevik Revolution."
Not knowing what more evil to do, and you did not want me to strike man, and man became
worse and worse.
He has accumulated so much pus within himself that not even the war, that is World War I,
managed to make this pus come out.
The war did not knock man down.
Now, for that I need to give you Isaiah chapter 2 verses 9, 11, 17, and 22, Isaiah 2 verses
9, 11, 17, and 22.
And in each one of those verses Isaiah said, "The pride of man must be brought low, otherwise
the kingdom of God can come, the pride of man must be brought low."
And the chastisement, when the Lord sends a severe chastisement, is to try and bring
some kind of humility into the human race.
He said, "The revolution will make him furious.
Now you know what the revolution is, don't you?
It's the Bolshevik Revolution.
Misery will make him despair and give himself prey to crime.
All this will serve in some way to make the rot which man contains come out.
And then my goodness, not indirectly through creatures, but directly from heaven will strike
man."
So some of the chastisements come from the earth, some from heaven.
And these chastisements will be like beneficial Jew descending from heaven, which will kill
man.
Now, that seems a contradiction in terms, doesn't it?
It will be a beneficial Jew on the whole human race, but certain human beings will die.
And he touched by my hand will recognize himself, that means will recognize his nothingness
and his sinfulness will wake up, repent, that is, from the sleep of sin and will recognize
his Creator.
Now notice that without a chastisement from heaven, this 1917, isn't it?
What month in 1917 did our blessed mother appear in battle?
May.
Well, she said fire from heaven, didn't she?
Yeah.
That's the thing I wanted to get you to remind me of, that he's saying that a chastisement
from heaven has to come.
Now, in Fatima she said it will be fire from heaven, that in the end will make man bend
the knee.
Okay.
Now we don't know what fire from heaven actually means.
So he will wake up and he will recognize his Creator.
Therefore, daughter, pray that everything may be for the good of man.
So here's Jesus saying that whether it is chastisement or healing that is sent to the
earth, everything is simply to help the human race get up and start the journey back to
God.
Because if they don't go back to God, the other direction is too terrible to think about.
So Jesus remained in his bitterness and I remained afflicted because I was unable to
relieve him.
I could just feel his bitter breath and I found myself inside of myself.
And I felt restless, the words of Jesus tormented me.
I could see the terrible future before my mind.
And Jesus to Camme came back and almost to distract me, he said, "How much love?
How much love?"
See as I suffered the pain remained in me, I would say my pain run, go and run, go in
search of man.
I want to give you a heading for this paragraph, "The Hound of Heaven", do you remember the
poem?
"The Hound of Heaven".
I fled him down the nights and down the days.
I fled him down the arches of the years.
I fled him down the labyrinthine ways of my own mind and in the midst of tears I fled
from him.
That's the history of the human race.
But with on hurrying chase and on perturbed pace, deliberate speed, majestic instantly
they beat those feet that followed, followed after.
It's the most wonderful poem and it actually describes not just the history of a particular
soul but the history of the human race.
And so that's why I think that if you put "The Hound of Heaven" here you'll get what
Jesus is saying.
But he decided to conquer the human race with pain and love.
His pain and his love and the pain and love of anybody who would join him.
And also the pain that people would experience themselves, like the soldiers in battle for
example, people sick in hospitals, their own pain.
And if there was even a spark of love in it, he could use that and join it to his and save
that soul.
So he said, "My pain, go, run and run, go in search of man, help him, and may my pains
be the strength of his.
As I shed my blood, I would say to each drop, run, run, save man for me.
And if he is dead, give him life, but divine life."
And if he escapes, run after him, beseech him from all sides, confound him with love until
he surrenders.
As the wounds were forming in my body, under the scourge as I repeated, my wounds do not
remain in me, but go in search of man.
And if you find him wounded by sin, place yourselves a seal to rule in order to heal
him.
Now I want to give you three references to this paragraph, John 5-19, 1 John 1-7.
And Revelation 5-9-10.
So Jesus said, "Everything I did and said, everything placed around man to put him into
safety."
You need to add the word spiritual safety.
In other words, to make him safe from falling into the abyss of hell.
You too, for love of me, do not keep anything for yourself, but let everything run after
man to save him.
Now that means all your pains, all your struggles, all your difficulties, all your love, all
your blessings, everything, make the whole lot of it run after the human being to save
them.
I think it's beautiful, isn't it?
Okay.
Let everything run after man, and I will regard you as another me.
I want to give you a number of references for that so that you'll see it from a scriptural
point of view.
Hebrews 9-14 and Hebrews 10-19, 1 Peter 1-2 and also verse 19.
So that's 1 Peter 1-2 and verse 19, 1 John 1-7, and Revelation 5-6, I don't normally give
you a full chapter, but that's the adoration of the Lamb, and it describes the new hymn
to the Lamb that you sacrificed yourself for us, and the saints in heaven are acknowledging
it, and Revelation 7-14, Revelation 7-14 is the final praise of all the redeemed for
what Jesus did for us with his love and his pains.
So October the 8th, 1917, everything that Jesus has done is eternal.
It's because it's done in the divine will, and the souls who love Jesus stand in for
him.
This is very important.
We are his feet to go where he wants to go, his mouth to say what he wants to say, the
heart that loves what he wants to love, and so on.
So Jesus said to Louis, "My daughter, everything that has been done by me is eternal."
So my suffering humanity was to be, not for a time, but for as long as the world is world.
Fantastic.
And since my humanity in heaven is no longer capable of suffering, I make use of the humanities
of believers.
Now I've changed the word creatures to believers, do you see that?
Using them share in my pains in order to continue my humanity on earth.
Now because this is one of the questions that people will ask you when you start giving
them any seminars or classes or anything, they'll say, "Well, if Jesus is in heaven
and he's in glory and he's not suffering at all, how does Louisa see him suffering
all the time?"
It's because Jesus can present himself in that state at any point, okay, but he's actually
illustrating something the church is going through.
So instead of seeing the church, how would you image the church, do you know what I mean?
He lets you see himself suffering like that.
Sometimes Louisa has described the church as an old noble lady who's nearly dead from
all the persecution she's getting.
But most of the time it's Jesus himself.
And because he shows that he is suffering, why does he show himself?
Because he says, "Whatever you do to the least of my brethren you do to me," okay.
And so it gets us to understand the importance and the enormity of the concept of the body
of Christ, that whatever we do, we're actually doing it to him.
But when Jesus would show himself as suffering, you'd have more motivation to do something
about it than if you see the old lady.
You mightn't have the same feeling for the old lady as you would have for Jesus.
So Jesus is knowing how to actually motivate us to do this.
But of course he's in heaven and he's in glory.
So he makes use of us and all that we suffer and all that we go through, whether it's external
or internal.
So for that I want to give you Ephesians 5-20.
So he says, "I make them share in my pains in order to continue my humanity on earth."
That's why you don't run for the Panadol first.
Just make sure you know whether the pain you're experiencing is something you can give to
him safely, if I can put it that way, do you know what I mean?
But when he says pains, he's not just talking about physical pains, he's talking about anxiety
and worries and distress and all kinds of internal sufferings as well.
So for that I want to give you Galatians 6-17, the marks on my body are those of Jesus.
And this with justice he said, "Because when I was on the earth, I incorporated all humanities
of creatures within me in order to place them in spiritual safety."
1 Corinthians 12, 12 to 30, that's the body of Christ.
So he incorporated all humanities making the mystical body of Christ.
Now being in heaven, I diffuse this humanity of mine in them that's in the rest of the
body of Christ, especially in those who love me, Philippians 3-10.
My pains and everything that my humanity did for the good of souls astray so as to say
to the Father, "My humanity in heaven was also on earth in the souls who love me and
to suffer."
It's not beautiful.
Therefore my satisfaction is always complete.
My pains are always in act because the souls who love me stand in for me.
The body of Christ on earth is the presence of Christ on earth, so we stand in for him.
So be consoled when you suffer because you receive the honor of standing in for me.
So I want to give you Colossians 1, 24 and 2 Corinthians 5, 20.
Now in the next passage, what can the soul who loves Jesus actually do for him apart
from offering the pains and sufferings that she goes through?
And the next one which is October the 20th, 1917 says, "You can make yourself a host
for him."
Having received Jesus, I was thinking of how I could render love for love and I found
it impossible for me to be able to restrict myself, make myself smaller as Jesus does
in the sacred host for love of me.
This is not in my power as it is in the power of Jesus.
So Jesus said to me, "My daughter, if you cannot restrict all of yourself within the
small circle of a host for love of me, you can very well restrict all of yourself in
my divine will."
That's why I say to the Lord, "I want to fuse all of me and all of you all the time."
I think divine will prayers should be short and sweet, you just get to the point.
I fuse all of me and all of you all the time.
You can very well restrict all of yourself within my will to be able to form the host
of yourself in my will.
For each act you do in my will, you will make a host for me.
Now the last time we had a message on acts, he said, "Each time your act makes a sun."
But of course, the sun and the host have the same shape because the host is the sun.
That's what they saw in Fatima, didn't they?
So you will make a host for me and I will feed myself from you and you from me, as you
from me.
That's John 6, the whole of John 6.
What forms this host?
It is my life in it, it's not the bread as you know, it's the presence of Jesus.
And so what makes us a living host?
It's the divine will living in us.
And what is my will?
Is it not the whole of my life?
So you too can make of yourself a host for love of me.
The more acts you do in my will, the more hosts you will form to render me love for love.
Isn't that wonderful?
I'm only going to do one more with you for today, that's October the 23rd, 1917, and
I have a VIP on this one.
The first act that Jesus did in receiving himself sacramentally, this is quite important
for us receiving him.
This morning after having received blessed Jesus, I was saying to him, my life, Jesus
tell me, what was the first act that you did when you received yourself sacramentally?
He said, my daughter, the first act I did was that of multiplying my life.
So put number one there, multiplying my life into as many lives for as many souls that can
exist in the world, so that each one might have one life of mine within herself, right?
That's fantastic.
A life that continuously prays, thanks, satisfies, loves for her alone.
Secondly, I multiplied my pains for each soul as if I were suffering for that soul alone,
and not for others.
And that supreme moment of receiving myself, I gave myself to all, number three, to suffer
my passion in each heart, to be able to subdue the hearts by dint of pains and love.
So he redeems us by pains and love, he sanctifies us by pains and love.
And giving all of my love, sorry, giving all of my divine life, I came to take the dominion
of all, but alas, my love remained disappointed by many.
Many means the majority.
And I anxiously await loving hearts, which in receiving me would unite with me to multiply
themselves in everyone.
Wearing and wanting what I want, so that I may take at least from them what the others
do not give me, and receive the contentment from them as conformed to my desire and my
will.
Therefore, my daughter, when you receive me do what I did, and I will have the contentment
that there are at least two of us wanting to do the same thing.
Now, beside that, I want you to put Matthew 1819, if two of you agree concerning any matter,
I will ratify it in heaven.
And while Jesus was saying this, he was very afflicted.
And Louisa said, "Why are you so afflicted?"
He said, "Ah, like a flood, they will inundate the countries, they are the communists and
the Illuminati, et cetera, okay?
The ones who were destroying the earth and still are.
They will inundate the countries, how many evils, how many evils, Italy is going through
sad, most sad hours, because Italy took on the communism rather quickly.
Call yourselves closer to me, be in accord among yourselves.
To be in accord is to be of one mind and one heart, or at least to be in some kind of unity.
And Louisa said, "Ah, my Jesus, and my country, what will happen to it?
You don't love me as before.
When loving me, you would hold back."
And Jesus said, "It's not true.
I do love you, but Louisa could not take it on board that Italy was, in fact, as bad
as it was."
So we're going to stop there for today.